there's your driver you just said it  ryan  hastily into the front court  flips it up and in plus the foul  the passion is back  and the cradle is there too come back  with a little bit of extra push and  adrenaline  and then he lets the crowd know mr books  is a team with 21 assists  on 28 made field goals  booker kept his left foot down twice  gets it to go plus the foul  [Applause]  and now booker says  i'll rock the baby as bazemore gets hit  with a technical foul yeah they're going  to tee up baze  did he pick up the i thought he  established the right first oh yeah i  think there's no question he traveled  ryan  he established the right and then  changed